[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous jeudi de novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
les titres et de cette édition une
journée du 2 novembre dédié au souvenir
des défunts et dans cette édition suite
du dossier de la rédaction consacrée au
marché de l'après vie dans les yvelines
reportage ce soir à guyancourt où
officie un crématorium particulier il
propose un service funéraire pour les
animaux il a ouvert ses portes fin
septembre à l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
l'établissement compte désormais un
centre de santé universitaire qui
propose aux étudiants des consultations
avec médecins généralistes présentation
avec notre invité emmanuel viken mathiot
médecin directeur de ce service de santé
universitaire enfin un retour sur un
événement original organisé hier aux
clayes-sous-bois le trait lwin moment
pour faire du sport est aussi fêter
halloween plus de 400 coureurs pour la
plupart déguisés étaient de la partie
pan de développer ces titres une voix
discordante au sein de la majorité
présidentielle le député président du
modem des yvelines bruno milian souhaite
l intégration de la grande couronne
francilienne au sein du nouveau grand
paris le parlementaire alliés de la
république en marche l'a fait savoir
dans une tribune publiée sur le jdd.fr
une position à contre-courant de ce que
prévoit emmanuel macron le président de
la république je dois faire des annonces
avant la fin de l'année sur le sujet une
métropole du grand paris intégrant
exclusivement les départements de la
petite couronne qu'il est prévu de
fusionner au lendemain de la toussaint
c'est aujourd'hui et la fête des morts
un jour de commémoration pour les
défunts et nous vous proposons depuis le
début de la semaine un dossier de la
rédaction consacrée au marché de l'après
vie dans les yvelines un marché qui
concerne aussi les animaux la perte d'un
compagnon est un moment difficile pour
les propriétaires un chien ou un chat
peut partager jusqu'à 20 ans d'une vie
d'un maître comment leur rendre hommage
une dernière fois c'est partant de cette
question qu'a été créé le crématorium
pour animaux de guyancourt marie
pannetrat et camille lambert offrir un
service funéraire à son animal dans la
dignité et le respect c'est l'objectif
de cet établissement installé à
guyancourt le crématorium pour animaux
accompagne chaque jour des familles dans
la perte de leur compagnon il propose un
service de crémation collectives mais
aussi individuelles au même titre que
pour un humain on va préparer l'animal
on va l'installer dans un petit cercueil
et on va procéder à un recueillement
c'est à dire qu'on va présenter l'animal
de personnes vont avoir un petit temps
qui leur est propre pour dire au revoir
à leurs compagnons éventuellement
laisser un petit jouet un petit mot si
les personnes le souhaitent elles
peuvent rester présentes dans la pièce
pour procéder à l'introduction ainsi
moment on va déposer le cercueil dans
l'appareil de création quand les
personnes décident d'accompagner leur
animal c'est un choix mûrement réfléchi
ça peut être comparée à un geste d'amour
parmi les 6000 à 7000 animaux traités
ici chaque année plus de la moitié sont
en crémation individuelle
un geste d'amour encore peu popularisé
seulement deux structures de ce type
existent en ile-de-france et les
propriétaires se déplace de tout le
territoire
on a des personnes qui viennent du
centre des personnes qui viennent de
l'as des personnes qui viennent du nord
nous avons des clients réguliers qui
viennent damien des clients de dijon
malgré qu'ils aient d'autres circuits
j'irai classique à leur portée voilà il
préfère vraiment et par habitude
et par respect et par amour venir ici
pour une crémation individuelle
classique comptait 237 euros pour un
chien ou un chat
créé en 1995 le site a été repris en
2015 par le siav service d'inhumation
des animaux familiers
l'offre est désormais plus personnalisé
et l'établissement a été modernisée une
crémation est actuellement en cours sur
cet appareil on va avoir une différente
informations
concernant d'une part la traçabilité
donc le nom de l'animal le numéro de la
crémation
et puis des informations techniques
notamment les températures et bien de la
chambre principale et de la chambre
secondaire
on voit que
la chambre principale est à 800 30
degrés
et on va dire
rassure requises pour
la crémation fabrice a rejoint
l'entreprise en 2014 après avoir
travaillé dans les pompes funèbres
ils sont cinq à accompagner les familles
quatre humains et en chat patch est ici
depuis deux ans son rôle est essentiel
patch est un collègue
voilà qui sert à l'accueil s'est mit qui
va accueillir les personnes qui se
présentent ici il va les accompagner
durant la crémation à leur apporter un
petit moment de réconfort et
éventuellement de rechange et des idées
devenu un compagnon indispensable pour
nous un compagnon pour adoucir la
tristesse que procure la perte de son
animal en france plus d'un foyer sur
deux possède un animal de compagnie
hélas pris place depuis septembre 2e
étage de la maison de l'étudiant à
guyancourt un centre de santé a ouvert
au sein de l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et pour en parler
avec moi sur ce plateau docteur emmanuel
viken mathiot bonsoir vous êtes le
médecin directeur de ce centre de santé
universitaire un centre de santé qui
remplace finalement un simple service
universitaire de médecine qui était
jusqu'ici proposé à albi vs q quelle est
la différence avec ce qui se faisait
avant
justement il remplace pas mais c'est une
évolution c'est à dire et ce qui existe
et persiste bien évidemment puisque
c'était un service de médecine
préventive qui existent au niveau de
chaque université 1 selon un décret un
service qui permet des consultations de
prévention auprès des étudiants primo
inscrits dans une université
donc la nouveauté est la nouveauté c'est
qu'on évolue ensemble de santé avec des
consultations de médecine générale qui
donne lieu à une prescription comme chez
un médecin de ville est tarifé
en secteur 1 avec tiers payant que nous
pratiquons déjà sur place les étudiants
vont pouvoir retrouver un médecin
généraliste des médecins généralistes
absolument nous sommes deux d'accord sur
une consultation deux fois par semaine
et effectivement c'est ouvert aux
étudiants en priorité est également à la
population générale puisque c'est de la
médecine générale
vous étiez déjà la responsable de ce
service universitaire de médecine qui a
donc évolué en centre de santé
ça faisait cinq ans que vous battiez
pour obtenir cette évolution c'est ça
alors on m'a dit on va confier la
direction du service il ya cinq ans en
effet et du coup ça m'a vraiment donné
envie d'évoluer dans une
enfin en centre de santé un combat c'est
peut-être beaucoup dire mais je pense
que c'est beaucoup de patience la
motivation de la persévérance le plus
difficile étant c'est le nerf de la
guerre de trouver les financements pour
pouvoir fonctionner dans les charges de
subventions d'ailleurs la rs l'agencé
régionale de santé a donné une belle
enveloppe pour on avait répondu
effectivement à plusieurs appels à
projets et la rs qui on a souvent qui on
a soutenu le projet équi validé
l'ouverture du centre de santé
effectivement nous a permis grâce à un
financement de d'acheter le logiciel
médical
et puis surtout le logiciel de prise de
rendez vous en ligne pourquoi pas c'est
important pour vous qui est cette
évolution c'est aussi aider les
étudiants à accéder plus facilement aux
soins bien sûr c'est une facilité
d'accès aux soins pour les étudiants
pour la population générale
évidemment aussi on sait que ça devient
compliqué donc c'est sympa donner un
coup de main aux médecins
de la ville et puis les étudiants oui
parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas forcément
des rendez-vous disponibles et puis ceux
qui sont loin de chez leurs parents qui
ne rendent que le week end c'est bien
qu'ils puissent avoir des consultations
de médecine générale en semaine sur leur
compte pour lui d'avoir eu le médecin
généraliste sur le lieu de résidence de
leurs parents de l'avoir directement sur
place à l'université ça facilite les
choses
alors juste au niveau des équipements
vous avez deux bureaux équipés c'est ça
pour pour ces consultations
alors en fait le centre de santé ils
l'ouvrent dans le service médical que
nous occupions déjà d'accord au niveau
de la maison de l'étudiant marta pan
dans laquelle nous avons emménagé en
juin 2016 donc ça ça lui en cours c'est
à guyancourt sur le site de ghlin court
puisque l'université et multicity le
centre de santé n'est que sur ce site de
guyancourt et effectivement il y a deux
infirmières qui travaillent avec nous
depuis longtemps dans le service de
médecine préventive et le centre de
santé nous sommes deux généralistes donc
sur deux cabinets différents au sein du
service
donc si vous avez obtenu d'ailleurs donc
cette évolution depuis septembre ce
centre de santé maintenant quels sont
les objectifs
est ce que c'est ça peut être aussi
d'avoir en plus de ces consultations de
médecins généralistes des consultations
avec des spécialistes c'est quelque
chose qui prospère alors ce serait
vraiment vraiment bien c'est ce qu'on
espère déjà augmenté
fréquence de nos consultations de
médecine générale pour commencer et puis
éventuellement ouvrir une ou deux
vacations par semaine des consultations
de spécialistes par exemple dentiste
pneumologues ou cardiologues par voilà
des spécialistes à qui on adresse
facilement les étudiants et puis le
projet aussi ce serait vraiment de
devenir centre de stages pour les
étudiants filières de santé les
étudiants en médecine en particulier
donc oui étoffer son équipe ça c'est
aussi oui c'est l'un des objectifs si on
obtient des spécialistes et qu'on étoffe
l'équipe aussi merci beaucoup
docteur emmanuel dickens mathiot d'avoir
été avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes
médecin directeur du service de santé
universitaire de l'ubs et excuse je
précise que les consultations se font
sur rendez vous de deux demi journées
par semaine ce sont les mardis matin et
jeudi après-midi au numéro qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran à je me suis trompé
peut-être surpris m c'est le jeudi matin
pardon et donc au numéro qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran pour prendre rendez
vous c'est une distinction chargée de
symboles l'union nationale des
combattants disent yvelines a remis un
drapeau à la section de trappes une
cérémonie s'est tenue à la salle jean
baptiste clément
en présence du maire guy malandain il
s'agit du drapeau des soldats trans et
opex pour transmission et opérations
extérieures remise honorifique le
drapeau est un témoin de l'histoire et
du devoir de mémoire c'est le troisième
que reçoivent les anciens combattants de
trappes son président au micro de
nicolas landry je suis un peu ému parce
que c'est notre troisième drapeau quand
nous donne à attraper la section de
trappes le premier drapeau cenap le
premier de la section en 1983 qui a été
créée après l'autre c'est en 2007 2007
parle
l'union nationale des combattants hélas
le troisième drapeau c'est soldats
français opex après un mois d'octobre
plutôt doux le début de novembre marque
le retour du froid est un élément qui
peut pâtir de cette baisse des
températures c'est votre jardin pour le
préserver quelques réflexes sont à
adopter comme continuer l'entretien et
même pendant l'hiver nicolas landry et
asma al wahsh sont allés glaner quelques
conseils du côté des jardins de la
vallée à magny les hameaux
qui a dit qu'il fallait attendre les
beaux jours pour jardiner en ce début
novembre l'automne s'installe dans nos
jardins et cela ne rime pas forcément
avec ramassage des feuilles mortes
on peut s'en servir comme de terreau
dans les massifs c'est à dire les
souffrait dans les massifs et après
bêcher donc les incorporés en terre ça
permet de créer un engrais vert
finalement voilà et donc est donc de
l'humus à terme et donc de l'engrais
pour vos plantes dans les massifs je
puise il tenait encore le froid ne nuit
pas aux plantes un végétal ne réagit pas
du tout comme un humain c'est pas parce
qu'il fait froid pour nous que le
végétal à froid
lui au contraire c'est vraiment l'époque
où il va émettre ses racines voilà donc
il a besoin de cette période de dormance
autre surprise de tonnes certaines
plantes sont encore en fleurs on prend
son mal en patience c'est quand même
dommage de se séparer de deux de
floraison actuellement l on va les
laisser tranquilles enfin le mois de
novembre
c'est aussi la période de plantation de
certains arbres fruitiers comme les
peaux mignon mais attention pour les
faire fructifier
l'emplacement est important on va en
chercher un minimum de soleil quand même
pour que la fructification se fasse se
fasse bien et surtout que le bourgeon au
printemps quand il est clos soit au
maximum au soleil pour pour essayer dé
danny gray les toutes petites gelées
ce qui est important c'est de forcément
de bien orienter son son sujet et bien
sûr de regarder que le col et c'est à
dire la base de la plante soit au niveau
du sol
ajouter une dose d'engrais naturel et il
n'y a plus qu'à attendre le printemps
pour la floraison
c'était une après midi de musique pour
la bonne cause le week-end dernier le
lion's-club de rambouillet organisé un
concert autour d'un instrument la
guitare sur scène des amateurs des
jeunes en devenir et des professionnels
retour sur cet après midi avec mélanie
poquet et nicolas d'andrus
[Musique]
donnez une scène aux artistes locaux
pour la bonne cause c'est dimanche à
rambouillet une vingtaine de musiciens à
jouer bénévolement au deuxième concert
guitare et solidarité on organise des
manifestations pour collecter des fonds
qui sont reversées à des actions
caritatives de rambouillet des environs
sud-yvelines ça peut être l'aide aux
personnes âgées aux personnes
handicapées aux malades mais ça va
jusqu'en afrique on est d'une
association qui a son siège à
rambouillet mais qui fait des puits
d'eau potable au cameroun sur scène
amateurs et confirmés se sont côtoyés
quatre heures de concert autour d'un
seul instrument la guitare comme marie
platel passionnés de musique folk
[Musique]
non
alors j'ai dit je chante à toutes les
occasions et mais surtout les occasions
caritatives et surtout même humanitaire
je vais vraiment la musique au service
de la bonne cause la musique c'est
quelque chose de complètement universel
donc par la musique on peut faire passer
un tel message
c'est un peu mon but de quoi l'amitié la
solidarité
toutes les valeurs humaines surtout
voilà c'est ce qui nous les expériences
de la vie bonne ou mauvaise cette année
les lion's club a récolté près de 2300
euros
une 3e édition du concert caritatif est
déjà en préparation
[Musique]
du sport à présent si vous êtes ballet d
hier du côté des clayes sous bois et que
vous avez vu des sorcières ou encore des
morts-vivants déambuler dans les bois
rassurez-vous vous n'avez pas été
victimes d'hallucinations
une première un train spécial halloween
était organisé plus de 400 runner en
grande partie déguisés et ont participé
et parmi eux michael l'hydro sorcière
chauve-souris mort-vivante antilles ce
mercredi 1er novembre la ville des
clayes-sous-bois pour participer à ce
premier trailer in une course à pied au
départ du parc jean carré y ont imaginé
par les organisateurs de plus au mois de
janvier dernier sur cette date il y
avait peu de courses dans la région donc
la cua n'y avait rien je me suis dit
mais pourquoi pas me glisser sur 7 sur
cette date du 1er novembre et ensuite le
trail il déduit trahi le wind pour faire
un petit clin d'oeil à halloween
les deux sources à cette course
terrifiante proposé de la marche
nordique et des courses de 10 et 18 km à
travers les bois
un programme qui a séduit plus de 450
âmes perdues sur cette première édition
on a fait mal aux menhirs soir ça nous
empêche pas de fêter et puis on vient on
vient sans aucune appréhension va faire
18 tranquillement sort pas de problème
perry d'e.on et hépatiques c'est top non
franchement c'est très très bonne idée
on est hyper content d'être là malgré la
horde de monstres qui l'entouré pendant
la course christophe deprez a eu le
coeur solidement accroché pour remporter
le 10 km en 39 minutes et 30 secondes
c'est vrai il faut gérer entre les côtes
le plat que je suis plus à chacun de
route donc le plat mal il ya les côtes
un peu plus dur mais bon autant aux 3 4
10 km finir finir hommes m'ont pas leurs
positions une fois l'apocalypse de la
course passé la matinée c'est évidemment
terminée par une dégustation d'une
potion à base de potiron
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
deuxième édition de ce trait l'oin
cauchemardesque
[Musique]
mais la saga a marqué des générations
harry potter continue de déchaîner les
passions et les fans yvelines ont été
servis le week-end dernier avec la
présence à versailles de trois acteurs
des films sur le plus célèbre des
sorciers
parmi eux stanislav janowski vous
connaissez sans doute le nom de son
personnage victor crom l'attrapeur
vedette de l'équipe bulgare de quidditch
et surtout participants avec harry
potter au tournoi des trois sorciers
dans le volet numéro 4 et nicolas landry
la rencontre est effectif
vous êtes victor crème ou stanislas
janowski stanis nationale ce qui au
stade
merci pour cette interview alors
pourquoi avez vous accepté de venir ici
aujourd'hui
tout d'abord c'est difficile pour moi de
refuser de venir en france à
c'est l'un de mes lieux de visites
préférer les fans sont ici incroyable et
vous savez tout ce qui concerne la
france est fantastique
donc c'est toujours un plaisir pour moi
de revenir pourquoi aimez-vous la france
d'abord je ne connais pas beaucoup de
choses sur la france mais je suis venu
quelques fois pour explorer le pays
les gens sont tellement incroyable
adorable même je me sens tellement bien
ici c'est pour ça que j'aime toujours
revenir pourquoi est ce toujours un
plaisir pour vous de rencontrer les fans
parce que ça permet de voir l'autre côté
du monde
être un acteur c'est être dans les films
c'est un côté voir la réaction des gens
vous savez ce sont les fans qui font ce
que nous sommes
passer du temps avec eux les voir
exister en train d'attendre un
autographe
c'est quelque chose de fabuleux pourquoi
avez vous accepté de jouer dans ce film
dont harry potter je ne sais pas comment
ça s'est passé
j'étais un jeune garçon à l'école ils
m'ont offert une place à bord dans harry
potter et j'ai dit oui pourquoi pas et
je n'avais aucune idée de ce qui allait
se passer ensuite
c'était juste un jeu pour
[Musique]
et aujourd'hui quel regard vous portez
sur votre expérience et sur votre
personnage victor crème c'est vraiment
un personnage aimé par tout le monde
ils gardent des générations de fans
j'ai même vu un jour un petit bébé
déguisé en victor comme le quidditch est
devenu un vrai sport aussi et bien sûr
chrome est une source d'inspiration
ce qui est incroyable avez vous des
conseils pour les joueurs de physique
s'entraîner beaucoup s'entraîner
beaucoup et tu atteindras ce que tu veux
être
qu'est ce que le film harry potter
représente dans votre carrière
et bien c'est tout simplement le début
de ma nouvelle vie
ce film m'a donné l'opportunité de
devenir un acteur de jouer dans des
films d'entrer dans le monde des acteurs
aussi ça m'a donné une notoriété dans le
monde donc ça représente le changement
dans ma vie quel est votre meilleur
souvenir dans cette expérience les
choses dans le film toutes ces choses
sont incroyables harry potter n'est pas
vraiment comme un film et huit films en
tout ont été faits est fermé chaque film
a été tourné sur des périodes plus
longues que d'habitude
normalement ces deux maximum trois mois
et avec harry potter avec tous les
enfants toutes les régulations ça
prenait beaucoup plus de temps on avait
besoin d'aller à l'école on avait besoin
de temps de pose donc on a tourné
pendant onze mois ce qui est extrêmement
inhabituelle ça nous a donné
l'impression d'être une famille et quand
certains acteurs partent et on était
triste
c'était quelque chose de génial et
dernière question comment utilisez-vous
cette expérience aujourd'hui je
l'utilisent tous les jours ça m'a donné
et ça continue de me donner beaucoup
d'expérience rencontrer des gens est
important parce que vous avez leur point
de vue
et ils vous inspire en vous suivant sur
instagram et différents réseaux sociaux
juste en lisant des commentaires qui
demandent de nous voir dans un autre
film
quel est le prochain projet cela me
donne beaucoup de motivation
merci merci beaucoup et quelques jours
de vacances encore pour les plus
chanceux et pendant les congés d'automne
à guyancourt les jeunes ont pu se
familiariser avec les sur ans et plus
précisément les illusions d'optique
ateliers proposés pour créer des oeuvres
d'art avec effets optiques
attention les yeux avec ce reportage de
camille lambert des formes répétitive
des couleurs vives quelques illusions à
guyancourt enfants et parents s'essaie à
l'art optique un courant artistique né
dans les années 60
aussi appelé aux parts c'est un courant
artistique qui vise à donner donc une
impression une illusion soit de relier
soit de profondeur soit de mouvement
dans quand on regarde une oeuvre ou un
tableau coloris eux mêmes leur image
pour se rendre compte très bien que eux
aussi sont capables de faire ça et que
ça donne à sa trompe l'oeil du
spectateur jouer les victor vasarely
grande figure de lot parts le temps d'un
atelier proposé durant les vacances
d'automne ce moment se veut avant tout
un temps des changes en famille
c'était l'occasion de faire une petite
activité avec avec ma fille a satisfait
on s'amusait du matériel à disposition
on a des profs sympa ça m'a plu et
légendes optique je connaissais
vaguement je faisais je fais des trucs
avec ma grand-mère des fois une petite
boîte à jeux mais c'est tout si on
développe en fait des axes des ateliers
parents enfants cela d'abord dans le
premier objectif c'est que
le parent puisse le papa ou la maman
puisse faire des ateliers profiter de ce
moment là avec son enfant dernier
atelier vendredi 3 novembre une
exposition sur les illusions d'optique
est proposée jusqu'au 10 à la maison de
quartier mono les oeuvres des
participants viendront la compléter pour
refermer ce journal le demos c'est un
dispositif d'éducation musicale qui
s'adresse aux enfants issus des
quartiers relevant de la politique de la
ville
objectif pratiquer la musique en
orchestre un stage de deux jours étaient
organisées dans ce cadre au château de
versailles en présence de plusieurs
saint quentinois mélanie poker et marie
pannetrat ont suivi des jeunes de la
verrière
[Musique]
rabia et maïs habite la verrière et rêve
de faire de la musique
elle commence la deuxième saison du
programme demos et apprennent la flûte
traversière auprès des professionnels de
la philharmonie de paris
il a travaillé la voie et on a commencé
à apprendre de nouvelles musiques
ben moi j'aime bien la musique et je
rêve de faire de la musique
[Musique]
oh
comme elle une centaine d'enfants
évinois s'entraîner vendredi 27 octobre
au château de versailles auprès de
professionnels
cette commune font partie de l'orchestré
demos on apprendre de nouvelles choses
on apprend des did not nouvelle note
l'idée de demos est de s'adresser à des
enfants issus de quartiers politique de
la ville qui a priori aurait pas fait de
musique par ailleurs et de leur donner
un instrument pendant trois ans qu'ils
vont apprendre en groupe
donc par petits groupes de 15 2 fois par
semaine et puis une fois toutes les six
semaines ils vont se réunir en grand
orchestre de 100 enfants environ et
travaillé toute l'année un programme
musical quatre heures hebdomadaires de
travail pour ces enfants âgés de 7 à 12
ans au programme de cette année la
bacchanale de camille saint saëns l'
orchestre yvelinois donne rendez vous en
juin pour un concert à la philharmonie
de paris
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
vendredi comme d'habitude place aux 7,8
l'hebdo avec nicolas kirillovitch l on
se donne rendez vous dès lundi pour une
nouvelle semaine d'actualité locale sur
tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]